ah there's a there is nothing easy
except reading these cards about
awarding an Oscar
nothing easy about making a decision
regarding five superb actresses giving
five very different and difficult
performances the woman who wins the
Oscar is simply the one whose
performance has pleased the voters a
little more than the others and by how
wide or narrow a margin one will never
know in this league there are no losers
those nominated this year are for her
portrayal of a woman's quiet desperation
as she sees her life her family and
ultimately her world disintegrating
around her Jane Alexander in Testaments
as the colorful witty multi-dimensional
Widow and mother who stormy relationship
with her daughter causes them both to
grow shirley maclaine in terms of
endearment
as a blue-collar woman who's growing
social and political awareness brings
knowledge passion and ultimately her own
defeat Meryl Streep in Silkwood
warm and affectionate portrayal of a
British working girl who longs for
something more and finds it through the
awakening of her own mind Julie Walters
an education research
and for her performance of brilliantly
etched moments from a marriage and a
life which are the center of the film
Debra Winger in terms of India
the winner is a rock
the winner is Shirley MacLaine
you
I'm gonna cry because this show has been
as long as my career
I have wondered for 26 years what this
would feel like thank you so much for
terminating the suspense oh my I am
nervous
I'm not going to thank everybody I've
ever met in my entire life although with
the way my mind has been going lately
probably everybody I've ever met in my
entire life and in the other wife I
might have had had something to do with
this
you know if some if terms of endearment
had happened to me five years ago I
think I would have called it a thrilling
commercial artistic accident but I don't
believe that anymore
I don't believe there's any such thing
as accident I think that we all manifest
what we want and what we need I don't
think there's any difference really
between what you feel you have to do in
your heart and success they're
inseparable Jim Brooks deeply wanted to
make a film about the defects and
imperfections and foibles of people in a
humorous and loving way and he had such
passion it was unbelievable to watch
he's being very modest with himself
tonight it was unbelievable his sense of
truth was so accurate that he he
overwhelmed his own insecurities and
Paramount's I guess we all did the same
thing I have wanted to work with the
comic chemistry of Jack Nicholson since
his chicken salad sandwich scene and
Easy Pieces
and to have him in bed with such
middle-aged joy
I wanted to work with the turbulent
brilliance of Debra Winger
she literally inhabited the character so
thoroughly that I thought for four
months I had two daughters but in the
end just let me say one thing
films and life are like clay waiting for
us to mold it and when you trust your
own insides and that becomes achievement
it's a kind of a principle that seems to
me is that work with everyone god
blessed that principle god blessed that
potential that we all have for making
anything possible if we think we deserve
it I deserve this thank you
you